[Music]
cipriana is with us in albany new york
hi cipriana how are you
hi dave hi rachel thanks so much for
taking my call it's crazy to be talking
to you you too what's up
so i have um a revelation that i guess
came upon me this uh this morning a
little background
um i am 27 years old um i have a
bachelor's i have a small business that
i run
and i am disabled i'm legally blind
um
but i am in a really unhealthy uh
borderline unsafe living situation right
now um
it's deteriorated it's a home with
family with my mother and brother and
his girlfriend and you know so it's a
it's a really complicated really
unhealthy living situation that i've
been trying to get out of pretty
desperately for the past six months um
and as you know the rental market is
insane especially in upstate new york
where i am it has the highest jump of
like anywhere in the country
and um because basically and so i've
been looking for six months for a place
to live i've got dogs that are
problematic breeds no one wants to rent
anyone with a kitty or a german shepherd
um and so i've i've been really
struggling to find a place to live and i
need to get out because it's really
honestly dangerous so i
i'm getting this money um i have a check
in three installments of fourteen
thousand dollars that's coming to me
from back social security
okay i tell you what i wanna hear the
rest of the story and give you a good
solid answer but i'm up on a commercial
cipriana is who we're speaking with
she's in albany new york
legally blind and is in an unsafe
environment with her current living
situation needs to move out having
trouble finding a rental and is getting
some disability payments we got started
on that part of it didn't get the rest
of that story
as a german shepherd and i think you
said a cat so it's having trouble
finding uh getting a place to live uh
and so on so that's what you told me so
far
um what was how much does the disability
pay out
so it's back payment of about fourteen
thousand dollars total that you're going
to get when will you get that total
um that first payment has already come
through and i think it's going to be
over the next couple months they made it
sound so i'll get the next one next
month and the next one after that okay
so you're getting four or five thousand
dollars a pop and in three checks
okay right are you working
yes so i've got my own pet care business
that i run and then i'm doing some
freelance
admin assistant work for a local company
on the side okay what do you make what's
your income
so it varies because i do pet sitting so
it's you know month by month it's a
little weird but on average
um income is between 25 and 35 hundred
dollars a month
okay and where do you do pet sitting
at your parents house
so i house it so i go to oh you go to
their house in people's houses your
house yeah okay
some of that sometimes i board i've got
some people that will come to my you
know where i live and leave their jobs
from a practical tactical standpoint i'm
not trying to be invasive or unkind i'm
just trying to understand
you have some sight but you are legally
blind you're able to get around it's
you're you're not completely black right
right so i have i have enough sight to
do what i need to do but i can't drive
and that's a big a big
issue with that how do you get to those
houses when you're house sitting
it's been it's been family my my father
was also laid off for the entirety of
the pandemic so he was helping me just
get me from place to place you know
because he didn't have anywhere he could
be so he's been helping me okay and your
german shepherd is a pet or a seeing eye
dog
uh the german shepherd is a pet and i
also have a pit bull mix so
okay
all right um
how old are you
27.
okay and so you're thinking of using
this money coming in to
get out of this situation and you said
unsafe starting to sound like you mean
physically unsafe
it it is my uh someone i live with is
an alcoholic and
you do not get along and there's been
altercations so violence it's not safe
violence yeah yeah okay sometimes people
say not safe they mean emotionally but
you mean physically
well that either definitely it's it's
emotionally unsafe i'm i'm needing
clarity here i'm going to understand
what i'm dealing with yeah
yes okay yes okay so that's that's where
that's where i'm at i've been looking
for six months for a place to live to
move out with my how old are you he
would give me
27. okay you told us that i'm sorry i
remember it now okay okay
um
so you you have an unbelievable
list
of
obstacles and difficulties
right
and
sometimes when i get in situations like
that
i stack them at the same level of
importance and they're not
in your story i hear you getting out of
there is top of all the lists
right
if you were my little if you were my
daughter rachel's little sister rachel
would have already gone over there and
kicked the guy's butt and um
then we'd have another problem but um
but the uh but we would have gotten you
out of there right rachel
well that's what i was going to say
sabrina is that i feel i feel like for
your safety as as you're talking and
explaining the situation
it almost becomes like that that is
that's the number one thing uh yeah
and i don't want to be the one to say
get rid of your dogs get rid of this you
know
i love dogs i mean they're my favorite
thing on the planet
cats not not so much but dogs i'd do
anything to keep a dog but you can't
afford them because they're keeping you
from getting out and being
safe unless unless you can find a
landlord that will allow you to have one
or both of these animals but the chances
are fairly low the pit bull's bad the
cat's bad
you might get the german shepherd in
somewhere if you can find a a landlord
that's sympathetic towards you and i
wonder if brianna with all the all the
stuff you've been doing with animals
over the course of a few years i guess
if there's anyone that would take
take the dogs for a period of time even
six to eight months a year
just so you know that you can you can
get them back eventually i've got to
trade your safety for you owning a dog i
know that's that's these are not on the
same level on my list
right and and that i hear you and i i
understand and you're you're not you're
not wrong but the two the two of them
are hard to place long story short one
is diabetic a lot of medical stuff i can
i can afford her medical stuff obviously
and the other one i'm not gonna allow
you to be in danger for the life of a
dog
right period so my question i've been
i've been trying to figure this out is
is it crazy that i've been thinking of
buying saving up enough and using this
money is it crazy because you're not
buying a house for you you're buying a
house for two dogs
well it's partially for me too i see
what you're saying no right now you need
to if you were smart you'd be a renter
you'd get your business stabilized you'd
get something uh close to the houses
that you
uh house sit for and you'd use uber to
bring you to those houses when you're
going over there to house sit but uh but
you know you got your two dogs back at
home then and and so um
i i don't like any of this i'm sorry for
you i mean it's a horrible squeeze that
you're in by this untenable thing that
your father is allowing under his roof
uh so that's a whole nother bag of
tricks to open up but that's his problem
no it's not my
dad is on site and he's allowing someone
to
threaten physically his daughter that
would happen about half a second our
place and then bozo be back
my stepdad my stepdad is in the in the
in the area he lives in the same
building he's not my actual daddy okay
well bozo would be bounced i'm just
telling you
but you know instead instead of my
instead of my sight-impaired daughter
being put having been run off by for
fear of her life
this is nuts
so but you got to get out of there kiddo
and so you know number one goal is leave
number two goal is find something that
allows you to run your business and keep
your income up so that you can stay gone
and i'd like for you to bank this 14 000
and not touch it you're gonna need the
emergency cushion
and then number three goal is try to
figure out a way that some of your
animals make the move with you if any
but they're
as much as i love puppies they're way
down the list here
i'm more worried about you than i am
your german shepherd
sure
i mean you call me up scared of the guy
you live with you got to hear yourself
right no and that's the only reason the
german shepherd is involved is because
i'm looking for a place with my
stepfather because he helps me get from
point a to point b he's his dog so i
could leave with just the pit bull but i
still can't find a place with her so it
doesn't feel well maybe he'll keep up
maybe he'll keep the pitbull since he's
keeping the german shepherd maybe he can
keep the pitbull and you get your own
place yeah
i i wish that was a possibility but it's
a they don't get along yet they're
separated it's a work in progress okay
it's so complicated no it's it's not
complicated you're making it complicated
because you're prioritizing your safety
the safety of a freaking pit bull that
won't get along with another dog over
yourself
it's a dog
okay don't get yourself killed over
trying to take care of a puppy
this is silly you're going to have to
break your cycle here you've got these
things two equal in your head they're
not equal and that's not to say we don't
love puppies but we love cipriana a
whole lot more than we love puppies
and we're afraid for your safety right
now because you told us to be
and so
we'll be praying for you but don't you
know
yeah
yeah
you can you'll find a place but you're
gonna have to put not put so many
limitations on the place
sorry kiddo sorry you're facing all this
it's horrible